claude carillo secrétaire régional du
syndicat de police alliance 91
bonjour claude carillo merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france avant
tout est ce que vous avez eu des
nouvelles des policiers attaqués hier
soir est ce qu'ils vont bien et dans
quel état d'esprit est ce qu'ils sont
écoutez mes collègues sa santé
heureusement pas de blessure pas de
blessure mais par contre ils ont très
choqués par ce qu'ils ont pu vivre
comment est-ce que vous expliquer ce
déchaînement de violences urbaines à
corbeil essonnes ça dure maintenant
depuis jeudi soir quelle est la genèse
de ce conflit
en fait si vous voulez y est depuis de
longs mois il ya eu la création du
quartier de reconquête républicaine avec
des effectifs qui ont été apportées et
une demande de résultat d'une mes
collègues travail quotidien si on va sur
le quartier on interpelle les cardinaux
et ont cassé des nombreux trafics donc
une pression permanente quotidienne est
là aujourd'hui il a fallu un événement
déclencheur qui a instrumentalisé un bon
les images que l'on a pu voir et
derrière après ça justifie aux yeux des
délinquants qui cassé et et d'essayer de
repos c'est danic avait que représentent
les policiers on vient de voir dans le
sujet de médias ce qui fit un tweet
d'alliance police dans ce sujet qui
appelle je cite à des peines
alternatives ou de la prison ferme pour
ces professionnels de l'ensauvagement ça
veut dire quoi qu'il ya toujours des
tensions entre les policiers et la
justice
alors c'est pas ça le débat on va pas on
n'a pas à s'opposer entre police et
justice nous ce que l'on veut c'est que
la police et la justice travaille elle
même dans la main et est là aujourd'hui
c'est le lot pour différentes raisons
bien évidemment il n'y a pas de sanction
ou sens que je vais donner pour exemple
les derniers événements que nous avons
eue il ya deux menus de cinq interpellés
sur les cinq interpellés les individus
sont convoquées ultérieurement par la
justice ils sont laissés libres dans le
quartier donc sans interdiction de
paraître dans nos quartiers donc vous
voyez ça donne un sentiment d'impunité
l'individu auteur
c est plus sévère eh bien écoutez ce que
la justice se montre sévère notamment
dans les sentiers et notamment c'est
qu'ils ne restent pas là où est ce qu'il
en est justement ce niveau de la
sécurité et qu'est ce que vous attendez
de l'état par rapport à ce lien police
justice et puis par exemple aux
effectifs vous parliez tout à l'heure la
rue des quartiers de reconquête
républicaine avec des renforts de police
a été demandée résultat on a vu la
semaine dernière emmanuel macron se
déplacer à marseille prendre des mesures
au niveau de la sécurité après les
règlements de comptes sur la canebière
des policiers envoyés en renfort des
millions d'euros annoncés pour un
nouveau commissariat c'est quelque chose
que vous aimeriez vous souhaitez quelque
chose de cet acabit pan département de
l'essonne alors tout d'abord confiance
cela commence par des effectifs valeurs
pérennes sont au département nous avons
vécu depuis octobre 2000 veulent des
réformes successives où il fallait faire
avec le nombre effectif nous a fait
miroiter de l'organisation mise à part
cette nouvelle organisation montre ses
limites aujourd'hui et il nous met 300
effectifs sur les départements ont
commencé à
travailler
contre ville maintenant le délai
qui n'est pas problème d'effectif et
la justice
les dossiers et pour accélérer les
procédures donc là aujourd'hui c'est un
manque de moyens humains manquent lot de
moyens matériels et il s'est vraiment
c'est vraiment le la aux bestiaux plus
par rapport aux bobos de la sécurité ou
est-ce que ça en est
écoutez le bout de la sécurité il se
tient maintenant c'est des décisions
doivent être prises dans les jours
prochains et des annonces doivent être
faites on en est un atome de ce qui sera
dit
pour revenir sur ces violences à corbeil
essonnes combien de temps est-ce que ça
peut durer encore sur l'envoi
surtout la question c'est comment mettre
fin à ses heures
écoutez je le répète tant qu'il n'y aura
pas de de fortes sanctions des
interpellés qui sont qui sont soumis à
la justice il y aura ce sentiment
d'impunité et ils continueront les
délais les délinquants je dis bien
encore ces jeunes déliquants par les
jeunes les jeunes délinquants ils ont
peur de rien ils sont jusqu'au boutiste
parce qu'ils ont ce sentiment d'impunité
il ne risque rien il ne dort pas rendre
de comptes et si d'un point de vue de
virilité ils devront montrer qu'ils sont
encore plus fort encore plus violent
donc là aujourd'hui today tout dépend du
travail fait par les policiers en nombre
parce que la présence des crs démontre
que si elle est effectif ça ne bouge pas
et en même temps
avec les leur envol le renforcement des
liens entre police et justice et qui
doivent travailler la main dans la main
et non pas les uns contre les autres
ça démontrerait un petit peu un travail
de fond merci claude carillo d'avoir
répondu à une question je rappelle que
vous êtes secrétaire régional du
syndicat de police alliance 91